l a tutti ragazzi questo video è roba vj
oggi siamo in macchina
allora ragazzi vi spiego cosa faremo
oggi io e il mio amico date come ho
invitato qua per fare questa challenge e
della private ma c'è un video mentre una
macchina va in giro e che è vero figo
soprattutto per il fatto che lo faccio
con una persona che non soffre di caldo
veramente caldo se vuoi i ragazzi perché
la universal ci ha proposto di fare una
challenge incredibile che consiste nel
truccarci a vicenda cercando di imitare
il suo personaggio si chiama mamma netto
e ha un sacco di tatuaggi in faccia a
più di lorenzo abbiamo quadrifogli di
riferimento in realtà la tipa la vedete
in sovraimpressione sappiamo la foto qua
dobbiamo cercare di giocarci a vicenda
mentre antonio mio zio guida quindi
ragazzine che possiamo iniziare questa
challenge zio quando noi in quanto sarà
difficile ti diverti una verità che ti
diverti con limiti nel corri micri
antonio o selezione dio
[Musica]
parini cosa riesce però il pagamento di
olio madonna dopo ti ammazzo
la base è quella parentela ma io ho
paura che i macelli metto questi
occhiali solo per protezione sexy
visto che abbiamo fare dei bei disegni
luce delle guance ma dalla volontà di
oggi va tanto vabbè allora mimaki la
maglia salatto infinite sui terreni ma
li stai mentendo al pocho è il foglio
qua se non solo una banana storia
[Musica]
sei bellissimo in questo momento per il
film sono sti nomi uno per set grazie
amico don ionio ed in questo senso non
ce la farò mai da sonia anche schifo dai
sanitari
basta come sei bravo bravissimo pietro
devi stare attento le misure attenti mi
pare una cosa chirurgica bravo pietro
bravo pietro bravo più così pietro siamo
i morti di pietro bravo ma dall'altra
poi c'è spazio di no stai fermo lì fatta
sì sì sei bellissima grazie sono uscito
bene basta antonia aveva finito la
parcheggiata in attimo che vediamo cosa
hai fatto bello
non oso immaginare come sono io se tu
c'hai le mani così lerch bellissimo
bellissimo bellissimo hai visto così
bello bellissimo sindaco gravissimo ma
questo pubblici siano è scritto scemo
chi legge non è facile arrivare un
bravissimo va bene ragazzi allora
abbiamo finita la prima parte della
sfida dove come a pitturato infatti
adesso per cambiare
e adesso inizia la parte divertente
vieni qua amico mio vieni nella con
vieni qua ieri qualche giochiamo antonio
adesso abbiamo questo bellissimo faccio
come cliomakeup questo correttore
bellissimo che vettori che si mette in
faccia per non si sa colmo di ora in ora
sembrano quelle sole forze
guardami
in qua
e crema questa pietra e crema stai
protetta riuscita e fredda come la tua
anima vera posto vieni qua bello e
difficile anche solo questa parte
[Musica]
ecco fatto ecco ecco allora con la
faccia ci siamo adesso dire che possiamo
apprestarci alla parte divertente
allora io gli direi di iniziare da una
cosa molto semplice da fronte ci sei ok
molto carico vado vado marco inseguiti
perché ti stai per abbronzare porca
vacca il casinò
il rischio è che a prendergli la faccia
è tutta una mummia 6
che bello mitica unificato bene questo è
venuta male ma non riesco ancora cosa
vuoi che faccia
vabbè allora si sono capiti non è facile
simulator
[Musica]
va bene vieni vieni vieni
antonio aspetta qualcosa ora guarda c'è
la sue labbra questa volta ci dica se
lui commessi bile questi qua che sono
tempo un po più anche nel film l'anno
truccati così severo ok interinale con
tanta aspetta aspetta aspetta che voglio
fare una rubrica perfetto ok c 6 c 6 c 6
antonio amico sei uguale bureau ha
sventrato veramente molto meglio per
tutti che storia
non si sa dove vai
tranquillo tranquillo aspetta aspetta
questa storia è più difficile di quanto
pensassi è facile a volte difficile
e vabbè dai simboli che sto facendo ma
antonio m poveracci bellissimo ragazzi
bene niente che abbiamo finito ho
definito un po la guancia nella
perfezionate abbiamo uno specchio il
ragazzo non che facciano stai dicendo
che ragazzi sulle puntate che eravamo in
macchina
poi troppo direi che possiamo
determinare questa sfida praticamente
ragazzi dovete decidere chi ha vinto tra
i due è ovviamente è venuto meglio se
dite che io sono venuto medie per capito
lui
mettete mi piace quindi ragazzi io direi
che questa sfida si può concludere qui
ringrazio da te come aver partecipato
per ogni fatto bello però di questo vino
sia piaciuto massimo piano è stato
maltrattato durante le riprese di questo
film trova per il momento è un mi piace
anche vari social conosciuto
tiziana presidi scrivetemi ricordatevi
che tutti quanti abbiamo bisogno di un
antonio che ci porti a scuola la mattina
da ragazza laudando ha salutato andò
meno
[Musica]
non puoi scappare
non puoi sfuggire
ha dei progetti per te
[Musica]
scusate sapete mica dove tom cruise ma
non è molto lontano non è molto lontano
si no su cinque minuti
ok per fenomeni stavano cercando tom
cruise che in mezzo alla gente grafici
molto gentile antonio vai che grazie